[Musica]
buonasera a tutti quando si parla di
innovazione secondo me bisogna parlare
di evoluzione e quindi mi piacerebbe
parlare a voi dei miei lavori e
dell'evoluzione dei miei lavori e
dell'innovazione che questi portano
questa foto questa immagine
ovviamente un fotomontaggio ma secondo
me è significativa perché rappresenta lo
stato attuale dove sono
sono appena più alla metà di quello che
spero sia il mio percorso professionale
che si è evoluto come vedrete in maniera
maniera abbastanza significativa
passando da la sperimentazione
progettuale nella quale i lavori e idee
che venivano introdotti in un progetto
poi entravano in altri progetti si
evolvevano alcuni rami morivano come un
albero normale evolutivo e altri invece
volevano in qualche cosa di nuovo siamo
partiti un po di anni fa con un concetto
molto cartesiano di causa ed effetto un
processo lineare di progetto per poi
arrivare più recentemente a una
interazione nel quale come vedete voi il
progettista in realtà non è altro che
una persona che all'interno e
all'interno di un sistema molto più
complesso in cui l'aspetto della
costruzione le aspetti intellettuali
sociali e ambientali si legano assieme e
quello che deve fare il progettista
l'architetto in questo caso non è altro
che cercare di capire come coordinare
tutti assieme
quindi volevo portarvi direttamente
nella storia di quella che la mia la mia
evoluzione professionale questo è il
primo edificio importante che ho che ho
progettato e realizzato a torino per le
olimpiadi del 2006 era l'oval lingotto
come vedete qui l'architettura è
cartesiana come la definisco ci sono
cause ed effetti si vedono 6 travi che
escono fuori dall'edificio e quindi si
capisce come
edificio funziona dice molto semplice
molto razionale
all'interno anche qui la razionalità
della struttura viene espressa in quella
che è la forma finale dell'edificio
realizzato per le olimpiadi appunto di
torino 2006 quindi l'aspetti funzionario
onu fondamentali è stato un simbolo di
quei di quei giochi
questi sono il team italiano della della
staffetta che ha vinto la medaglia d'oro
ma la nostra cosa importante il nostro
approccio importante era quello di
pensare a quello che dovesse essere il
il manufatto nei 20 anni successivi e
quindi dieci giorni dopo la fine dei
giochi il nobel è stato completamente
svuotato ed è diventato una macchina
flessibile per un multi zona privè
polivalenza d'uso e quindi sta ospitando
tutta una serie di manifestazioni varie
l'ufficio si trova di fianco al lingotto
è stato anche un forte elemento di
rigenerazione urbana all'area del
lingotto prima dei giochi era un'area
era un non luogo
e adesso fra villaggio olimpico e ovale
e lingotto stesso hanno creato quello
che uno dei poli della città di torino
contemporaneamente all'ovale abbiamo
progettato e realizzato il centro
acquatico di di fiume
anche qui vedete che l'approccio
progettuale era molto simile a un
edificio estremamente razionale si è
pensato a quelli che fossero gli aspetti
di sostenibilità quindi volumetrie basse
per diminuire i costi forma delle
coperture che si apre prima
dell'inserimento dell'edificio
all'interno del dl del contesto che era
un grosso parco
dopodiché abbiamo iniziato a capire come
poter cambiare ed evolversi e come il
processo progettuale potesse svolgersi e
i due progetti successivi che vi farò
vedere sono a soci
questo era soci prima dei giochi è un
fotomontaggio di soci prima dei giochi
del 2014
invernali e questo era quello che è
stato realizzato poi a soci all'interno
noi abbiamo progettato all'interno di
questo grosso complesso due edifici
l'ovale per il pattinaggio di velocità
che questo edificio che vedete che ha
avuto come caratteristica rispetto a
quella di torino sa di avere un luogo
come avete visto prima noi stavamo
intervenendo in un luogo non c'era
niente prima e quindi non sapevamo a che
cosa rifarsi
il tentativo è stato quello di rifarci a
quella che era l'origine dello dello
sport del pattinaggio che era quello
delle montagne quindi ricreare
all'interno del nostro del nostro
progetto
la sensazione di essere immersi
all'interno delle rocce delle montagne
quindi forme frammentazione del dei
volumi e all'interno di un bosco
artificiale che diventava la copertura
allo stesso tempo abbiamo anche
progettato il palazzo per il pattinaggio
artistico e anche qui avevamo il grosso
problema di come relazionarsi al
contesto perché non c'era un vero
contesto quindi se da un lato abbiamo
cercato di farci che l'edificio fosse
una macchina che è altamente flessibile
per permettere l'uso di di concerti di
sport di congressi di conferenze
dall'altro lato ci dobbiamo rifare a
qualche cosa e ci siamo rifatti a quelli
che erano il movimento delle artiste e
delle pattinatrici quindi i vari salti e
le evoluzioni delle pattinatrici che
sono diventati poi all'interno riprese
all'interno delle facciate facendole
diventare facciate quindi avete visto
che rispetto ai primi due progetti
questi qua mostra un approccio diverso a
quello che è il
l'architettura parallelamente ci siamo
occupati anche non solo di sport ma
anche di edifici elevati di torri
questo è un progetto a dubai nel quale
abbiamo cercato di esplorare come la
sostenibilità potesse entrare
all'interno del nostro edificio e quindi
ventilazione naturale illuminazione
naturale interesse all'interno del
nostro edificio andando avanti in questo
processo evolutivo del del progetto un
milestone abbastanza importante è stata
quella del progetto dello stadio di le
mans nel quale noi abbiamo cercato da un
lato di far sì che il luogo diventasse
un luogo di attrazione delle persone e
dove la forma diventasse molto legata a
quella che era
l'approccio al allo stadio per cui
questa grossa coda che voi vedete non
era altro che l'ingresso principale in
modo tale che le persone in tracce
all'interno dello stadio e poi si
disponessero nelle nelle tribune
la copertura è aperta e chiusa su tre
lati aperta sul lato per permettere al
sole di illuminare meglio il campo e la
forma è derivata da quella che era la
nostra visione
siccome all'interno del circuito di
lehmann delle 24 ore dove le macchine
arrivano a 350 chilometri all'ora
era la dare la nozione dello spazio che
si torceva al modificarsi e
all'aumentare della velocità
questo progetto segnato un diciamo uno
spartiacque perché non certo momento
abbiamo iniziato a chiederci in realtà
dove stavamo andando e soprattutto dove
andava all'architettura e soprattutto
dove e come richiamare nell'architettura
quella che era la natura e abbiamo
analizzato e visto che questo avviene
sostanzialmente in due modi fondamentali
una cosa usare gli elementi naturali
come elementi di costruzione
queste sono delle straordinarie
impalcature che vengono fatti in cina
con il bambù l'altro invece quello di
utilizzare la natura come forme e di
prendere le forme della natura di
inserirle all'interno dei propri edifici
quindi le foglie che diventano edifici o
l'acqua le dune del deserto
in realtà e questi si sono trasformati
in due approcci fondamentali una colla
dell'high tech
questi sono due edifici lollis a londra
e l'aeroporto di stansted che riprende
la natura come elemento tecnologico e
l'altro invece l'architettura
decostruttivista lizzati e di herzog de
meuron ed i fan gary che riprende la
natura come forma
in realtà però il nostro ragionamento è
arrivato a dirci che la natura non
funziona in nessuno dei due modi e
l'evoluzione della natura degli elementi
naturali non funziona nessuno di questi
due modi funzionano attraverso i
processi matematici che genera
l'evoluzione cosiddetto crossover io
sono un architetto non sono un uno
scienziato però il crossover non è altro
che attraverso processi matematici
andare a far sì che quando due elementi
si evolve si due elementi si congiungono
e si evolvono in un terzo elemento
questo non è altro che il modo di
adattarsi nel miglior modo possibile a
quelle che sono le condizioni locali e
le condizioni ambientali locali ed è la
teoria darwiniana abbiamo noi cercato di
applicare questo concetto in
architettura e e abbiamo visto che
effettivamente ci ha portato a delle dei
risultati che sono stati assolutamente
inaspettati e secondo noi abbastanza
straordinari il primo progetto quello un
altro progetto per le olimpiadi altro
progetto sportivo dell'ovale di piùun
chang per le olimpiadi del 2016
siamo partiti da quello che era
l'origine dello sport viene praticato
nei grandi laghi del nord europa e nel
nord america e all'interno dei canali
dell'olanda ghiacciati ovviamente e è
uno sport che si basa sulla natura
dopo di che il sito era un sito
straordinario era un bosco vicino alla
cittadina di pian chang nella quale
esistevano degli alberi particolari una
specie di pino che esisteva solo in quel
posto lì tutto il mondo e con la
mentalità asiatica ovviamente se invece
le olimpiadi loro volevano smantellare
il bosco e creare e inserirli
all'interno al nostro è difficile
lui mi ha detto ma forse è meglio
cambiare sito siccome il cliente non ci
sentiva abbiamo cercato nel nostro
progetto di far sì che il nostro il
nostro edificio diventasse un tributo a
quello che era il sito a quella che era
la natura del sito e cercare di capire
come riuscire a meglio interpretare
all'interno del nostro progetto
quello che abbiamo fatto quindi è stato
creare un grande bosco naturale cercando
di capire come funziona la natura
rispetto a quello che vi ho detto prima
e cercando di capire come questa potesse
diventare un edificio stesso quello che
abbiamo fatto non è stato altro che
creare una struttura che forse la più
leggera possibile all'interno della
quale ogni elemento funzionasse per
quello che era la natura non funziona
come un elemento bidimensionale con un
elemento tridimensionale e quindi nella
struttura dell'edificio ci sono queste
grosse foglie che diventano elementi che
sorreggono l'edificio stesso ma
diventano anche elementi che frangi luce
per non far arrivare in maniera diretta
alla luce sul sul terreno di gara e
soprattutto anche elementi che servono
come acustica per far sì che il suolo si
diffonde in maniera corretta
quello che abbiamo fatto è stato quello
ti quindi riprendere tutti questi vari
parametri inserirli in un algoritmo e
far sì che il computer generasse quella
che era la forma migliore che si
adattava a tutti i parametri che gli
avevamo detto e quindi abbiamo generato
questa questa questa copertura che ha
sembra
sembra in realtà assolutamente
irrazionale ma una logica matematica
profonda al suo interno stessa quando
abbiamo fatto per un piccolissimo
progetto che di fianco al centro
acquatico abbiamo fatto a rijeka che vi
ho mostrato prima il quale non è altro
che la abbiamo utilizzato lo stesso
materiale e abbiamo utilizzato un
algoritmo matematico per far sì che il
materiale cambiasse colore a seconda di
quelle che erano inclinazioni del sole e
della luce e quindi si vede che il
supporto dell'informatizzazione e stata
assolutamente fondamentale per quello
che era il risultato finale
un altro progetto secondo me equamente
interessante è stato questa sala per
concerti che abbiamo progettato per lo
stesso cliente che ci aveva
commissionato il lavoro dei soci quello
che abbiamo fatto anche qui è stato
cercare di rivoluzionare quello che era
l'approccio al al progetto e
all'architettura facendo sì che in
realtà i parametri fondamentali che
hanno determinato la forma vera
dell'edificio non fossero formali ma
fossero funzionali e in questo caso era
il diagramma dell'acustica e la e quindi
cercare di capire come ottimizzare
perché un una sala per concerti un
teatro in realtà quello che deve far
funzionare deve funzionare assolutamente
come un oggetto musicale quindi deve
diffondere il suono e quindi l'acustica
era assolutamente fondamentale per cui
noi abbiamo preso il diagramma
dell'acustica tipica di una sala per
concerti e l'abbiamo interpretata
all'interno del nostro progetto
facendola diventare essa stessa la forma
dell'edificio e quindi è la forma di
questi elementi in legno che diventano e
che si adattano a quella che è il
parametro funzionale e non viceversa
ci sono altre immagini interne ed
esterne
l'ultimo progetto che vi voglio vedere
voglio far vedere è un evoluzione e dell
evoluzione finale di quello che vi ho
appena detto questo in realtà non è
stato fatto nel mio studio ma è stato
fatto da me
durante il mio periodo che ho passato
due anni fa in a londra da una società
di architettura che si chiama gangster è
il concorso per l'ovale per le olimpiadi
di pechino del 2022
quello che abbiamo cercato di fare era
anche qui far sì che la funzione
dell'edificio le tradizioni e le
metafore locali della cina in questo
caso di pechino e l'architettura locale
si fondessero all'interno di un unità
gestualità progettuale e quindi
sostanzialmente quello che abbiamo fatto
era cercare di capire quelle che fossero
queste cose è una delle peculiarità che
abbiamo trovato è il concetto che hanno
i cinesi del lotto e della foglia di
loto e soprattutto la resistenza fisica
e e strutturale che hanno queste foglie
abbiamo cercato di comporre assieme a
quelle che erano poi le facciate e far
sì che di tutto
questi vari elementi diventassero un
oggetto unico e quindi sostanzialmente
abbiamo creato un grosso una grossa
foresta un grosso lago di loto che poi
cascava ai lati nelle facciate che
diventavano poi delle facciate vetrate e
questo è la parte finale del l'edificio
l'edificio completato questo diventava
ed è questa la cosa interessante del
progetto era un elemento unico che viene
poi ripetuto e quindi la copertura e le
foglie di loto diventano degli oggetti
strutturali in ferrocemento all'interno
della quale correvano gli impianti
correvano e venivano localizzati
l'impianto di illuminazione questi
elementi poi con un algoritmo matematico
e quindi attraverso la progettazione
computerizzata venivano localizzati nei
punti esattamente dove dovevano entrare
e doveva dovevano essere messi e questo
è poi il l'immagine appunto finale
dell'interno di questo grosso spaccio di
questo tentativo di artificializzare
quella che è la natura attraverso dei
principi matematici se sono appunto
delle facciate
e il modellino che fa vedere bene quelle
che erano le nostre intenzioni stesso
volevo far vedere se parte sì un breve
filmato che spiega meglio quello che io
ho detto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e quindi siamo ritornati all'inizio a
cercare di capire dove si era come si
evolve e quello che sarà il nostro
futuro
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]